durch tune day zu treffen nach Corona
ich würde gerne eure Kommentar
aufgegriffen so wie zum Beispiel davon
Tobi 1892 beschreibt Liebe Donat brutali
Reportage vor der wir immer danke messi
ist Kompliment aber logisch sind
Kommentar
Sowa erwarte viel Spannung und Kritik
und das Bar Kommentar würde gerne
besprechen über Videotelefonie und all
später der Politologen
mit der Frage hey ähm die Spannung die
Maßnahme kritische Bewegung inwiefern
wie groß das bedeutet dir für die
politische Landschaft in der Schweiz
[Musik]
Kommentar vor lassen und nachher
Schwierigkeiten
also Simon Eschler schreibt ich frage
mich führen diese Menschen auch ein
glückliches Leben haben die eine
glückliche Partnerschaft ein schönes
Leben mit dieser negativen
Lebenseinstellung raubt man sich ja die
Lebensfreude jetzt immer noch in der
Vergangenheit leben und sich zu ärgern
bringt doch nichts
nachhaltig verändert das mit dem
Abstimmung so aber jetzt rein auf die
emotionale friedenheit im Lappen ist das
Wetter auf dem Auto Niveau oder wie ist
es zerstörbar
[Applaus]
ganz viel Wichtiges im Leben mit Bürger
zu sprechen
[Musik]
Perspektive aber schön
Roman Kaufmann schreibt ich glaube es
gibt unzählige Möglichkeiten Brücken zu
bauen sich aus Holz
so physikalisch solange in dieser
Diskussion die eine Seite von der
anderen verlangt das nur sie zuständig
sein die Brücke zu bauen werden wir an
kein Ziel kommen
ja morgen finde das ist ja sehr schön
sehr schöni USA und ähm ich glaube der
Bürgermeister
Emotionen
unternehmensachen
gemeinsam schaffen
hallo
Ciao Petra
Rosmarie schreibt der Schaden durch die
Politik und Mainstream Medien ist zu
groß und Brücken bauen zu können
das ganze wirklich
diskutieren
ist es wirklich Sinn oder ist es weniger
Sinn machen
der Nacht schrieb was mich an dieser
Dokumentation am meisten aufhorchen
lässt ist die Aussage von Patrick
jetzterklärung
Rechtfertigung
ich weiß dass in diese Bewegung sehr
viele Mühe haben mit Politik und mit
Wahlen und aus dem System raus wollen
und solange das System noch funktioniert
das wird es hoffentlich nicht mehr sehr
lange diese Aussage lässt für mich ein
sehr großes Fragezeichen beim Demokratie
Verständnis übrig denn was ist das
System dass sie sonst wollen ja
es gibt
[Musik]
Reaktionen bekommen
also der Film hat mich zurücklang mit
der Humor also
schreibt die Doku die übrigens wirklich
gelungen ist zeigt wirklich gut keine
der beiden Seiten hat die gesamte
Weisheit mit Löffeln gefressen die
Fakten aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht
müssen von beiden Seiten anerkannt
werden sonst fällt die Grundlage zur
Diskussion
gesagt
Studio gemacht und danach unterbringt
aber der
parametera
ähm
also frag ich nach
jawissenschaft verwandeln
Gohan 999 geschrieben es ist bekannt
dass an diesem Demos sehr viele
rechtsextreme Gruppierungen und
antisemitische Menschen teilgenommen
haben diese wurden weitestgehend von den
Maßnahmen kritischen toleriert das hat
nichts mehr mit Meinungsfreiheit zu tun
hier wird die Pandemie und die Maßnahmen
lediglich instrumentalisiert um Hass
zubereiten
[Musik]
real,-
veröffentlichen im Internet also
[Musik]
aber inzwischen
ja sie schon rechts konservative Kreise
hey schachi die Bewegung das muss man
sagen
politische Haltung oder die politische
Ziel war nicht absolut nichts
gemacht bin in dem Filmprojekt und
ja Stichwort Brücke
zulassen aber mit Fakten
passiert diskutieren
ich bin Schweiz kanadischer Doppelbürger
und wohne in Kanada das Misstrauen in
die Hauptmedien der Maßnahmen Kritik
kann ich nachvollziehen da ich diese
Medien in verschiedenen Ländern
verfolgte ist mir eines aufgefallen im
Vergleich zu Kanada Deutschland
Österreich den Niederlanden und
Frankreich war der allgemein sehr eng
gehaltene Diskurs in der Schweiz am
vielfältigsten da die schweizerische
Politiklandschaft viel vielfältiger ist
als hier und die vielen Parteien
systembedingt irgendwie mehr
zusammenarbeiten müssen ist auch der
Diskurs über dieses heikel Thema in der
Schweiz aus meiner Sicht am lebendigsten
gewesen spannende Blick auf Schweizer
Blick hat die schweizerische
Politiklandschaft ist der politolog
Michael Hermann in trifi
Finger in Frage die Maßnahme kritische
Bewegung das hätte es für eine Dynamik
gebracht und
ja was bedeutete
schweizerische politische System
[Musik]
das bedeutet für ihn aber es wird euch
Meisterschaften das bedeutet das für uns
Schweizer
ich finde das wirklich spannend das ist
wie er für eine große Teil von der
Bevölkerung Nummer 1 Pandemie ist hinter
uns
gar nicht so schlecht gemacht
wo die Pandemie nicht
aber wo wohnen auch die Pandemie sowieso
sichtbar und fühlbar macht etwas
für die ganz wichtig dass ich nicht
einfach den entstanden sondern dass die
lügt viele Lücke überfordert schon das
Unbehagen mit dem Medien mit dem
Wissenschaft mit dem Start
[Musik]
so richtig
respektvollen
juni 2021 die vermeintlicher offenbar
nicht
40% für das stimmt also für größere
Gruppe und das hätte nachher eine
Sitzung für das mit der Schweiz im
Sommer
die diskutiertheit das stimmt mich
extrem aggressiv ich sehe heute sozialen
Medien und spannende Nummer drüber
abgestimmt haben
und es hat nach dazu geführtes sehr
vieles von der Dynamik halt ist
Schweizer
Modeller
Direktor Demokratie
Initiative
sie ihre Veränderung starte was wir
heute gesehen finde
Bandage diskutieren aber aber auf die
lange Frucht hilft es man sich stehen
wenn man die verschiedensten einige
irgendwo integriert immer dann als
Gesicht geht und nach lauter Lösung